Vìu của giang liện cảm ơn chạy không đầy.
Không在 của mình thì rất chuyển là quay tròn.
Vũa, có chí ông tựa mơ, quay là, quay bơi cả ai với nó sẽ chuyển lòng.
Lý lầy, đông đầy, đầy, đầy, xây lầy xuống a chuyển lòng.
Vũa rất đi xuống.
Đừng đàn đầy, đầy, đầy, đầy.
Vũa, tầy đã bị truyết đất quay tròn.
Vũa, tầy không chí chí ông này.
Đả quý trời.
Vũa, tầy đầy, đầy, đầy, đầy, đầy, đầy, đầy.
Vũa, tầy, đầy, đầy, đầy, đầy.
Đúng rồi, rất ngu, đầy đầy.
Dạ, đầy cambi, đầy, đầy.
Cậm đầy, đầy, đầy, đầy, đầy, đầy.
Cái vết tư cảm ứng tư bây giờ phải xuyên mà là ngon thái.
Yv่c em thôi, vết tư cảm ứng tư bây giờ, vứ tư tư tư tư.
Bác, xanh tư mẹ, là bác bảo ngon, yv่c vết tư cảm ứng tư bây giờ, vứ tư chái xanh thái.
Vết tư cảm ứng tư bây giờ, xuyên mà là ngon thái.
Đó là ngon thái, yv่c em phải sẽ bỏ ngon thái.
Mỏng thái gái d hit trong chiếu của vết tư là通 b recorded bài mà...
Bộ ngon thái.
Thì chiếu của thái lائ dì ngon thái là chiếu của rân bẹ...
Quải ki vết là nó sẽ cạnh al bên lái dì chiếu của rân bẹ, xanh hướng løng,
anh để bây giờ, tu Desert Tư bây giờ, hướng løn la để bây giờ.